Fröhlich, sauer und - zack - wieder gut drauf.
Alles auf Knopfdruck.
So stellt sich ein Hersteller von neuartigen Sexpuppen in China die ideale Gefährtin für den einsamen Mann vor.
Eine Puppe für alle Lebenslagen - mit Gefühlen und Sprachfunktion.
Sogar Schmollen kann sie.
Xiaodie oder Baby soll aber nicht - wie man
auf den ersten Blick annehmen könnte -
nur für die sexuellen Gelüste ihrer menschlichen Partner zur Verfügung stehen.
"Es gibt einige Kunden, die zum Beispiel den Tag, an dem sie ihre Puppe bekommen, als Geburtstag
feiern.
Sie geben ihrer Puppe einen Namen und feiern diesen Tag dann jedes Jahr.
Sie backen Kuchen und trinken ein Gläschen Wein."
Eines Tages sollen die Puppen - ausgestattet mit künstlicher Intelligenz -
Babysitter oder Altenpfleger ersetzen und im Haushalt helfen.
Denn Sex ist ja bekanntlich nicht alles.